citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to watch Ahsoka episode dose today
if you didn't catch our reaction episode
one that is of course live here on the
Chanel John you good yeah I'm I suck
could okay almost
um it's episode
the Clones the the what look what are we
doing the clan red attack of the oh God
that this is not the intro I wanted it
to be
sure you're looking for alrighty guys
we'll use the force to leave a like all
right guys whatever let's go into it
traffic keep forgetting to do this uh
all right well like you had to watch a
walk for a super sexy rechecks at our
patreon patreon sticking with your own
copy of Ahsoka we also cover things uh
exclusively over there several shows
reaction highest watch along is included
thank you to all have joined let's get
to it I'm just so anxious but you and I
both know Sabine gives you the best
chance of reading that mess
that just looks like a different galaxy
The Dread
Sabine
you're annoying me I unlocked it
so you went to the right there were two
galaxies
did you keep a record of what you found
the turrets destroyed it
how many drawers were there
two I took one out formidable droids you
need my help
no
you've done enough
clearly I could hear Anakin saying that
to her yeah
never got stabbed and have to roll your
eyes at the same time
Vibe I know the haunting Samurai affect
is so cool
his presence is extraordinary
place the Poland
better I believe we have located at the
reflex point on cetos
damn they are steps ahead
surrounded by giant taser lifts
such a Rebels conundrum
per gallon for real perguel
in trouble double double it doesn't seem
to fear the Pergo in that moment well
the Pergo would be the way to travel
from that destination as if there's a
hyperspace line there yeah oh we've
never left the Galaxy before
[Music]
buddy
oh there we go
thanks for the heads up uh smart she
asked earlier how many droids there were
you still got it
very attention to detail of how heavy it
felt
take up an arm or a leg and it just
keeps coming
of the humanity you can recover the
droid's memory and find out where it
came from very clever
perhaps we should perform this operation
somewhere else I say go for it because
you're a hologram
thing like this in the movie Alien 3.
it's overheating switch it off not yet
come on Harry just watches all of her
friends blow up
you got it this Droid came here from
corellia okay
[Music]
Morgan ellsmith Had factories on
corellia her Imperial operations should
have been dismantled after the Rebellion
unless let's get going you need to
recover
fine
only a flesh wound
let them have a scene
tell that to her
you need to help each other you heard
her she doesn't want my help yes she
does
give me a little stubborn too now get
some rest
you're gonna need it Chris such a
special character hair has become a full
blown General
[Music]
foreign
do some witch magic let's get some green
Flames going oh man I would love to see
some of that in live action get some
green Flames witchcraft
what does she possess it or is she just
a descendant of it this place was not
built by the Jedi whose work is it
ancient people
Galaxy
fascinating would you like to see it
if this is what I think it is I think
this may be the beginning of the griss
oh really someone's getting circumcised
oh
[Music]
sweet
just once in this life I want to stand
inside of a hologram or I mean this is
why thrawnjo in the Empire he needed
allies he feared this
oh
[Music]
yeah those are perkil Target acquired
that
and animal
finished wow thrawn calls to me
across time
space we're going to be going to some
unknown regions
the eye of cyan is on its way here I
have Scion morocc will complete his task
see that he does why are they working
with like what's their motivation not
the first Jedi to Veer off course
countuku had Noble intentions once what
happens when you find thrawn or some War
Brothers
hope in the beginning new beginning
[Laughter]
for us power
power this is a fascinating setup I mean
if you were to feel so helpless during
Order 66 power never feel helpless again
this was always one of my life oh wait a
second
that's uh
from the ghost isn't that hero ship
hey yes yes it's the little ship that's
part of the ghost yeah we'd appreciate a
look at her former facilities and
operations well I am quite busy at the
moment clearly I couldn't make this a
more formal inspection if you'd like
that won't be necessary General please
this way
and New Republic bureaucracy
you will still find X Imperials at every
level of the new republic government
that's reassuring don't you worry about
their loyalty not at all the average
worker doesn't care about the nuances of
Galactic politics and you and the
businessman General my loyalty is to my
investors
I'll leave the politics up to you Dark
Side long time ago in a capitalist
hellscape far away late stage capitalism
at its finest boys I was wondering if
you consider bring
uh-huh no no no no no no maybe we're
both past that I think she could use
some structure so could you Ahsoka you
you could use a little bit of your old
spunk what makes someone ready huh
no
like love
so do they
I love you too Greg
yeah
I know
whoa
anyone can get stabbed with a lightsaber
it's like one of those old shots
like that I don't know there was that
one person an Obi One
I don't know who you're talking about
I don't want to talk about that I see
you still have your lightsaber Ezra's
lightsaber
um he passed it on to you so you have
since made your own modifications so it
is now your lightsaber hey Phil young
says so it's yours have you kept up with
your training obviously not well perhaps
it is time to begin
well everyone's on this Mission she quit
on me the past is the past move forward
Let It Die kill it if you have to
General cindula thought your insights
would be valuable
and Lady Tano agreed
this feels so much more like a Sabine
show you have never indicated that you
wanted to come back forgot how annoying
you are logical
don't worry you're a great middle man I
never had the talent the abilities not
like Ezra
I see your game the only time you are
wasting
is your own
[Music]
I get it's Rebels music our board and
primary investors have first look at all
unique Hardware it's price point and
distribution is that a hyperdrive core
oh man what class of Starship are they
for
uh
let's see
front row classified
I'm a general not
who who I cannot unseal the document
without authorization well then I'm
authorizing it how much
what the hell what are the types of
Droids do you have in operation here no
HK class assassin Droid I should think
not I have seen such a Droid
oh he knows something where is this
Droid now I believe it is
Department transport
oh great well stop it
I can't do that General they've been
cleared for departure
no stop him Quick Draw whoa
just lose an arm yeah sure did
yeah we don't worry about the Imperial
sympathizers we don't worry about
loyalty here yeah God damn it's so good
oh God damn it's so many entrances you
make exits really extrances just throw
your lightsaber
yeah
oh
he was with them earlier
he's with the bailing in them earlier
do they have the lightsaber out it
looked like half a lightsaber held The
Inquisitor and that is definitively a
red lightsaber
got these money
money shots man
jeez look at that stance
ah you punk warm up brown
cool
JJ
who are you
that is a great question gateway to the
Mind's Eye this is General sendula I
ordered you to stand down and return to
Port immediately
do some piloting in live action
right now would be a good time to bring
in the ghosts
chill
Zang
[Music]
yeah oh sweet nice
if this is a familiar face
oh okay that's definitely whoa whoa
Jesus
such a cool shot
that's amazing can't just shoot it down
it would crash into the Port City
Collateral Damage
and don't miss this time
[Music]
I never miss
who is this guy
why does he only have armor on his upper
half
what a great aerial sequence
what a great like way to do a locked off
shot but with a subject no I did not go
through is you look under the backup
battery
found it oh
wow wow
jeez who is this dude
oh my goodness Jesus
oh but
what oh what a boss all the alliances on
this team here
yo witch you got the middle ground Jedi
stuff it's all the remnants former
Inquisitor all the malevolent remnants
yeah
go
nice there you go Chopper good work
Chuck
you got him
tell me you have good news we got a
tracking device on that transport all
right then
game on all right all right all right
zero Dawson does play her a lot more
stoic I hope that changes as we make
progress here
Moxie I mean she's aged though you know
but she's still Ahsoka but I'm
justifying you know
don't give me defending you know it's
Gotta until we're at the last episode
what does it matter it's broken now
sad Mandalorian ruined it yo
during her training with Kanan because
she wasn't the strongest with the force
he had her use these traditional
Mandalorian things to compensate I hope
that we see some of that
put it on
oh sick this is the way
cut her hair
Action Hero cutting hair and give
herself a perfect bob cut it without
looking in the mirror yeah so I'm
talking about
oh
the classics of being here
she leaves the hair on the ground how
can they still be loyal to the Empire
it's not loyalty
it's greed
you're on a roll it's almost like
there's reoccurring themes that are
always happening in Star Wars
oh yeah classic I'm ready
laughs
smile
take it I know
[Music]
gotta get you a big chair to sit on now
oh is this the ending of rebels is that
what we're doing right now
[Music]
oh but I believe it may be exactly that
yeah we're redoing it
not draped in white unless that already
happened
but they're starting over again this is
poetry it rhymes
does it
or is it just an homage to it yeah
nice haircut
for me
you got perfect layers with that one
knife swipe it's crazy we better get
moving
[Music]
this is the scope of these things the
lighting and everything is beautiful
take us out
Padawan oh
[Music]
yes
maybe they're just redefining what it
means to be a Jedi
oh sick
look at this super hyperspace
Intergalactic hyperspace Drive
[Music]
this is so freaking ominous soon the eye
of Scion will be complete and we shall
deliver
the eye of Sauron the appearance of
Ahsoka Tano and corellia troubles you
it does he has his Riveter her presence
in the force is elusive at her
determination
is vivid to kill her
it'll be a shame
oh there's so few Jedi left what's your
game Man Truth
I really love the look of this show
even the way the Hologram had that kind
of like ripple effect happening yeah
it's like his actual particulate kind of
percolating yeah
Seth Green
Robot Chicken makes sense animation I
don't think it's perfect pick those
knits oh yeah you know I'll be picking
those nits got to get every part of the
Star Wars Market take it away John ah
this is quite enjoyable I've been very
much enjoying the uh it makes sense as
to why they put these two episodes out
in tandem it does feel like yeah this is
the act the First Act of the journey
we're culminating everything we've set
all the pieces but it just maintained at
least through these two episodes through
two different directions and whatnot it
just has maintained this very assured
confident steadiness of hand and uh and
yeah I really enjoy the space that they
communicate all this stuff with they
give everything it's time and you're
able to kind of get pulled into yeah
that there is something like Melancholy
at the core and there's like a Paul
hanging over our main Rebels crew and
then you also have this sort of like
very at ease dark presence especially
with um
Balin what's his name bones or Balin
hell
something skull skull there you go Bale
and skull there you go uh I don't know
what in doubt just go with the first
name yes Balin yeah
um yeah I don't know like it still feels
like this momentous kind of neck and
neck
um you know hunt cat and mouse almost
um but also just whilst taking its time
like I think that's just a testament to
how well this has been kind of paced and
conceived is that it's never feels
rushed but it also feels like it's fully
able to spread out and take its time
without indulging too heavily in that so
yeah
Mikhail
this is the beginning of something that
I am
ready for it's the first time in like
Star Wars content since I was a kid that
I genuinely
am like
I I have no idea
and yet I have so many ideas at the same
time and it it's gotten my imagination
going in the most marvelous and
wonderful of ways I think it's brilliant
to take this adventure to a different
galaxy
I think it's brilliant to have
antagonists like Balin who represent a
new type of of nuanced villain
and I think that this entire series
everything we know about thrawn is he is
a very interesting nuanced villain in
that their intentions and their actions
and where our characters fit into this
narrative
we're about to experience like for the
first time not just like oh good guy
good guy bad guy bad guy I think we're
about to see something
genuinely gray in nature
um and I I say that with like fear and
hesitation because every time we've
thought we were gonna get that they
always go back to what's comfortable
um I think this setup is great I am glad
that we are going to leave behind the
very kind of muddled storytelling that
is the new Republic and all of that I
feel like they did a nice little taste
that gave us what we needed and now
we're going somewhere completely new I
think what's interesting is there's a
couple connective threads that I'm
really excited to pull on in the next
episode I'm really interested to see who
is that Inquisitor you know at the end
uh of the empire particularly as the
last of the Jedi were really kind of
officially wiped out
um it was kind of alluded to that
Palpatine uh removed the inquisitors but
you also have all these examples of
children who or Force sensitive being
kidnapped
um I wonder if some of the characters
referenced uh in animated form
um I'm just so curious who that
Inquisitor is and I feel like it has to
be somebody based upon the way in which
they've built him up but also what an
interesting Alliance
um you know and I I think that also kind
of sets up an interesting
who who are the other characters that
might come out of the Woodworks I didn't
think it at the beginning of this and
and with all the materials that came out
but part of me really wonders like is
there going to be a connection to like
calcas and that storyline and in a way
if we were to move and have a whole
separate narrative that exists in
another galaxy
that can do its own thing without
undermining what happens in the sequel
Trilogy and without trying to like
Backtrack on what Disney did you know
and I kind of love that that's a good
place for all the great characters that
we love that we wish and probably should
have been a big part of the sequel
Trilogy now have the opportunity to have
their own story in a new Galaxy where
it's a complete clean narrative Fresh
Start
um I think this is the beginning of
something much bigger for Star Wars I
still feel like they were building to
the development of the first order
though via the Mandalorian and all that
well and I I think that that will be
part of it but the the threat that we
have looming here strikes me as much
scarier than
Palpatine in the New Order and all that
sort of you know um
and like not to get too deep into to
Canon and and you know this that and the
other thing but like do thrawn's biggest
fear and the reason that he joined the
empire was to recruit an ally that could
help the chiss ascendancy fight
an enemy that is beyond anything that we
can comprehend
yeah so it seems like what he's forming
here are not
necessarily pawns or henchmen it seems
like he's forming alliances he's got a
witch on his hands he's got Jedi's on
his hands he's got an Inquisitor on his
hands which is why I think our big
reveal is going to be that Ezra this
Jedi that we've been looking forward to
meeting in live action might be actually
part of the team and and I think that
maybe Ahsoka and Company might find
themselves joining that Alliance which
represents something so unique and
interesting to Star Wars where now
they're they're not just kind of
defending their own isolated interest
within the Galaxy but together they're
defending the Galaxy I don't know I feel
I think I think that might be too big of
a flip to do you know like at the end of
the day while thrawn while always has
been thrawn's one of those characters so
I see people can defend going he's not
exactly a villain I'm like well you know
he can have a lot of good intentions but
at the end of the day the guy's a
villain like he isn't villain but he
there's a there's a pretty [__] up no
he he has it
was justified well I mean all right so
you guys have seen Oppenheimer
yeah let's go that route no no I'm
serious let's go that route I mean a lot
of the decisions that thrawn makes and
that he's done is because he understands
that his people are facing extinction
throughout Rebels for instance when when
he and Hera really went face to face his
respect and admiration for her culture
and preserving and protecting that
history that's not a villain attitude
that's somebody that understands that he
needs to do what he needs to do in order
to save his people but he doesn't want
to erase other cultures in history like
he he never ran well with the other
Imperials for a reason and like we even
saw that a little bit in the Mandalorian
as they're like well you know Thrones I
like there are some that admire him and
love him but
um he's a complex blue fella I will give
all those complexities at the end of the
day he always aligned with the Empire
because the empire was the only force in
the Galaxy strong enough to stop an
impending threat you can just fight
however you want at the end of the day
he still worked with the Empire all
right we worked with the Soviets during
World War II Greg it's not the same yeah
but we hit a lot of stuff from them and
we side-eyed them every step of the way
yeah and then we hired the Nazis to help
build space spaceships because
our moral principles are fluid
um no it's
I I hope that as Star Wars fans that we
are given those sorts of interesting
dilemmas of characters because it is
really really frustrating when somebody
comes and they've got horns on their
heads and they've got red and black
faces yeah and they're terrifying
looking with their yellow eyes they're
real Angry yeah I'd say it's the same
way of how you can understand the
motives of Thanos but at the end of the
day the guy is a villain nah dude Thanos
is right yeah I mean Thanos is uh I'm
not going to defend Thanos
if I'm remembering correctly was not for
the Death Star
he had some other like the last time we
saw some good let's look at the last
time we saw thrawn in order to get Ezra
he just started annihilating people on
lethal in order just to make a point to
Laura like just innocent civilians I
mean
is America a good country
why are you making about that I'm
talking about the wrong talk about agent
orange I mean like but that's like the
thing is historically speaking
I'm not saying he's a good guy but I'm
saying that in his mind he his ends
justify the means what's better
sacrificing the few they do you know
it's the trolley problem I think I think
he's on a mission I think the scary part
is when someone can see that he when
when we go he's actually a not I think
we have to do there is a line that has
to be drawn when you can see that
someone at the end of the day does skew
towards the villainy yeah and I think if
you lose sight of that line that's where
it's dangerous I think the audience
needing to reconcile that isn't I think
it's a more interesting debate challenge
yeah oh that's a much more like what
happens when we get there and then it's
like oh man if our characters don't like
like grin and bear it and deal with the
fact that these guys are trying to
protect the Galaxy well I think like no
I mean even even with Ron that there's
something that separates him as his his
care he does
unlike a Vader or something who kind of
can disregard life he can he has a
there's a preciousness he can hold to
history and life so he does he does
separate and stand out from them which I
do think makes him a very compelling
person I could see how he could actually
form an alliance because he's someone
who could look at the bigger picture at
the end of the day and not just and
hopefully they don't just turn him into
I want to dominate everything and that
was never his his motive
um no and in reading the books like
he has some really like meaningful
relationships and and cares for people
including Anakin Skywalker yeah
um so I don't know speaking of
Skywalkers
I'm really interested to see if we will
see a chess Skywalker
um which is like a force sensitive chess
youth that is able to navigate
hyperspace lanes that are in the unknown
regions wow
you got that all from this one episode
no well I I had I had I had nothing but
time in the woods this summer to read
all wrong content and throntin yeah
thrawn tent yum
um yeah well we'll see what happens
either way this is different and I'm
real jazzed about something different
I'm jazzed about it too I do think from
a storytelling standpoint though that
I do I do feel like
this show can might have a challenge
where it can keep too much of an
emotional distance with the way their
portrayals go down
because there is a lot of stoism
stoicism
does that mean that is something that's
Pride
they've taken a lot of the it is
interesting seeing the characters they
brought over from the animated mediums
that they have adapted them into this
aged up matured interpretation
but a little bit I wouldn't say void
that have dialed back a lot of more of
the animated personality of all I would
say that for everyone here Sabine Hera
and especially Ahsoka and that was
something that stood out to me already
with ahsoka's appearance in Mandalorian
and it especially stands out to me here
is at the end of the day we have to
connect to these characters on an
emotional way in order to stay on board
for the journey like I love the mood I
love the aura I love the Menace I love
this this
I love all of the I actually really do
love all of that uh my concern is
if if it just stays that way for so long
that the there can be a lack of a
pulsating feel and a drive that you kind
of need to have
that you know what I mean that thrust
into like oh my pulse is racing as
opposed to Observation because right now
there is a bit of a a distance and a
Detachment yeah you know so a question
for you then
I'm not on exactly on the same Throne
page as yeah that's fine okay my good
man but a query about Ahsoka as a
character and what it would take to
create that emotional because because I
agree jokes at the moment
there is there is not a lot of chemistry
at the moment and I hope that changes I
think with anyone I hope it's I hope
it's a choice a deliberate choice
and then all of a sudden we have like an
amazing pair part of me wonders and I
mean there's been rumors about it of
Ahsoka flashbacks with Hayden
Christensen
um to her as a Padawan
and I had this dream okay I had this
dream that they didn't cast
uh Rosario Dawson for the younger
version they brought Ashley
Eckstein back exactly that makes sense
because I feel like to be able to give
people that may have never seen the
animated young happy version of Ahsoka
um that it would be good to tap into a
little bit of that magic and also just
create that narrative thread
um
well like do you think that would be
enough to I think we're gonna need some
flashback that explains exactly why her
demeanor is so such an antithesis too
where we last left off with her because
when we last saw her in Rebels that was
when Ezra pulled her out of that
firewood Vader so she dealt with that
Revelation and then she went her
separate ways where where did she just
go back to the the temple ruins is that
where she went in the world Between
Worlds uh yeah she went she went right
back to the temple ruins but then she
went back
she found them all and then she helped
them with all their stuff that they were
doing
um okay is there like a whole Gap there
that I because I I'm just going off of
what happens
yeah yeah she she disappeared when off
was doing some Adventures while the and
that's the part of the Gap that I think
we need to fill in to fill in to
understand why she's morphine and if you
buy the amazing Ahsoka book for 1990 is
that Canon uh I'm trying to remember if
they touch on I know I don't think I get
that because some of these books and
stuff are like Canada the the Ahsoka
book is Canon but
um
I don't think it goes on that long in
her narrative like there is clearly a
gap that needs to be filled but also
like losing several years of your life
after finding out that your former
master
killed a bunch of kids this is the big
bad I mean it was uh it was the big
threat to the Empire probably right
underneath the emperor yeah it probably
set her back a little bit
um yeah and I think that's that that's
part of the I think we have to factor
that into it at the same time yeah there
is that that he brought the chemistry
question and I do think that like every
individual performer is so good I agree
and I do think you have a great point
with exploring the gray which is what
I've I'm saying likewise I've been
saying I want this the these live action
shows to do more and I feel like that's
why we started off with Balin and doing
her name yet oh the other one I don't
think she has a name yet
um but she will The Apprentice The
Apprentice I think that's why we started
off with her with them because they are
I know gray Jedi is is something that
like pisses off the internet yeah it
does but they do seem to exist in eggs
I think there's a an appreciation for
the tradition and for the force
um but historically speaking you know
canonically there's been plenty of Jedi
that have veered off that path and that
have done their own things you know I
mean I feel like Jedi Survivor did such
a great job exploring that theme
um
but
you know it's I think their chemistry is
great though their Mass like for two
very serious people that are like
murdering people like oh they're a great
little pair yeah I don't know you mean
like bailing and yeah and it definitely
feels more organic than Ahsoka and
Sabine in ways I feel like that whole
crew like Morgan ellisbeth and the group
of them have even though you haven't
been spending much intimate time there
is something that feels like a more
complete unit and I do like the
mirroring of like oh we have sort of
remnants of so many different uh casts
of people and different specialized you
know abilities and things like that and
and that you know plays off of what the
you know Rebels crew is also
um but yeah they just they are all
organized and they're going after their
goal it almost feels like they have the
plot momentum and our main characters
are all catching up to that and sort of
coming back together as a unit yeah
but if you haven't seen it it doesn't
feel deserved or
at least I imagine that's what it like
like at least I know the magic like when
I see Harrison Doula like my heart like
flutters a little bit because this is
like a character that I've invested a
lot of time in if you're brand new to
this there's no
I don't know it is I agree with you Greg
there it is missing uh chemistry and a
little bit of of magic and dare I say oh
maybe some comic relief
um in the form of of a character like
Jar Jar Binks gotta get him that would
fix it gotta get him back although you
know who would actually be a really
great addition to this that I don't
think the lad but
um I feel like Zeb is a great fine line
between somebody that's funny if I yeah
if I wanted to simplify it I would say
that there is a weird lack of excitement
like I'm excited for what's to come
there's a lot I'm looking forward to but
when we get to action scenes I don't
find them I think they're cool to look
at but I don't find the action
particularly exciting I think you need
one character who is kind of into this
and is not just doing it out of burden
and purpose like somebody who is a bit
more of like a swashbuckler or something
yeah I am
uh
yeah yeah yeah I I completely agree with
that
um and maybe they'll pick one up along
the way
um I think when Zab comes because Zeb
has to come into the show I don't know
that's expensive
that's why they just threw him I think I
think it's like one Cameo man uh like a
big big it would it would be amazing but
if you're gonna do that that at that
point do it like get the crew like you
know but I don't think they're going
that direction I I think that the the
Ahsoka and Sabine are going to this
galaxy
yeah like don't get me wrong like I like
Rebels is a real Hit or Miss show for me
actually I'm gonna be honest it really
is like I thought I think the show was
remarkably repetitive a lot of the time
and then and then when it's great it's
so great you know like that that's
that's one so I'm not by any means this
guy was like oh I just wanted to be
season five of rubble that's not at all
my my my taste because even I would say
even with season four a lot of times
because that show has a certain pattern
and a certain repetition and then when
it decides to really just Propel forward
and do some different stuff I'm like man
this show isn't firing on all cylinders
um and I always thought Rebels was at
its best when it was taking itself the
most serious as well so I'm by no means
here going I want it to be like the
quirky fun animation but there is
something here that right now I'm like I
I I still feel kept at a distance right
now as much as I'm loving the
observation piece and and I thought the
first episode was more transportative
than the second one sure I wonder if
that's a Dave filoni
because if you notice most of the stuff
that he's done in terms of the live
action where he's been you know in the
director's chair or the writers the
Gunslinger they're very relatively
serious episodes not the gunsling except
for the Gunslinger but I but I I can
imagine that he's kind of living in this
interesting shadow of like yeah he's the
cartoon guy and now he's trying to be
something more serious I wonder if
that's a hard thread for him as he's
making that uh transition professionally
yeah either way but he's doing an
extraordinary job I think visually this
is a really compelling piece and I do
agree that oh this is actually exciting
to see that they're building something
where I'm not like okay so we're just
filling the Gap to the first order
version yeah yeah we have a foregone
conclusion and we're just doing stuff in
between that's why I think it is smart
to have because I don't know the history
all that well but yeah like something
discovery of force and everything
divided up and that's why we got like
hyperspace lanes and [__] like that in
Pergo I like it's all like fragmented in
my mind yeah of how it all goes so to I
make to have this op this this
unexplored region where you could have
like this other story take place it's
not it's not a Multiverse it's just yeah
now please John I thought this did a
nice job to end off on a note that
suggests that those missing elements of
chemistry and camaraderie might be just
around the corner now yeah or at least
some kind of like engaging character
friction because they're setting off on
the journey and they have the she calls
her Padawan yeah well they have who Yang
here to help balance us which is a a
great character but not the funniest
character in the world you know get some
of that David Tennant wit I mean it's
it's it's great
um
yeah well uh we'll see there's a lot of
characters that I want to see in live
action name them all you want me to name
all of them alphabetical yeah but
actually actually Hondo Hanover would be
great
no that's exactly the kind of character
that we need yeah that's it and mole
bring it back again
no he's dead now right more spiders at
this point yeah yeah yeah oh no he died
in Rebels yeah yeah he's dead he's dead
he did yeah sometimes the timelines do
confuse me I want someone to put
together the most ultimate watch the
ultimate chronology just like put it all
in order from Clone Wars to New Hope to
the prequels and like inner splice for
them so
The Inquisitor Theory okay hear me out
is there an Inquisitor who survived
that we don't see I mean theoretically
like there's several inquisitors that
were never fully identified I don't know
and I don't think it's any of the ones
that we've met thus far although you
know it would be really interesting to
see um
oh gosh uh Barris
although that didn't look like a bearess
uh
remind me of bears bears is the one that
played a role in
framing oh there's she's the one who's
straight up a straight up framed or
something she's someone who completely
framed him she was mildly oh yes yes
they were friends and then yeah yeah I
always felt like that was an interesting
narrative
inquisitor's name yeah but it was it was
heavily implied that she became an
Inquisitor um and we never saw really
I I guess I don't know if I'm completely
wrong feel free to rip me apart in the
comment section but
um
but the other that's what led to the
additional it would thematically tie in
because that's what led to her the
rejecting the Jedi Order yeah we should
go and look at that person again and see
if that's even a remote possibility that
Inquisitor is that a thing that we can
do
we can rewind
yeah John that's Ford
it could be it does look feminine it
could be it does it does look a wee bit
feminine
um
and it would also kind of explain the
this and I definitely felt like they've
met before I'm you I'm used to
inquisitors vocalizing too yeah well it
would make sense not to do that if it's
somebody that is yeah it's this one felt
like very it's very quiet also who like
Ahsoka like wrecked every other
Inquisitor effortlessly it would make
sense that this would be a more
challenging tool for her if it was Paris
um I would be super jazzed connective
tissue or it could be our favorite
little Wookie Jedi
actually no the bearish theory would
line up because when when she revealed
herself to
um doing it she she thought like the
Jedi went down she was she thought she
was putting an exposure on the Darth
paths the Jedi went down so it would
make sense that she would want to become
a Jedi Hunter
but I don't think she necessarily wanted
to become a Jedi Hunter as much as she
was forced into it this character
is no longer an Inquisitor
they I think right right yeah if bailing
represents this notion of
the Jedi like you don't have to be Sif
you don't have to completely be consumed
by hate however to be weak to not take
the offensive to fall into the plight of
the Jedi and they're very narrow-minded
philosophy that puts the whole galaxy at
risk yeah Balin wants power not for the
sake of power but for the sake to
protect what he loves which is what
Anakin want to do
but Anakin fell to the dark side in that
process I think there's something really
interesting going on here and I think
Ahsoka on a on a level
philosophically probably aligns closer
with Balin than one would expect at
first glance because her same feelings
about the Jedi
and their lack of action their lack of I
mean even we saw it in the very last
season of Clone Wars when she pushed for
them to go to Mandalore to protect
people why shouldn't the Jedi do their
job of being the Defenders and
Protectors of the Galaxy well I think
the debate there's a debate around is
Ahsoka a Jedi or not right like that's
that is such a question mark
um
but I think this show is intentionally
going we can Define what a Jedi is like
I I think we can land in a scenario
where
um uh oh my God supine or Sabine can be
you can be a Jedi and then not be using
the force somehow I think there's a
scenario where they can land in that
identification yeah
um you have these characters like Baylin
took on an apprentice but Balin does not
consider himself a Jedi yet he's got
himself an apprentice who's trained in
the Jedi ways you know and then Ahsoka
herself rejected the Jedi Order
and yet you know everywhere she goes
she's like there's a Jedi but she says
she's not a Jedi yeah like this is
that's one of the words she said to like
it to even Invader like I'm no Jetta
right like she does she herself doesn't
call it so I think maybe also why isn't
she with Luke like like she she can't be
with Luke because Luke's view of what
the Jedi Order should become yeah he's
what the Jedi Order was and
that's because of poor writing it became
a self-fulfilling prophecy and it ended
up the same exact thing happened all
over again but that's why I think uh her
art ahsokas will be that Clarity um on
what
you know the audience fights about I
think
yay I I I hope anyway that what is
transpiring here
thematically as Star Wars gets itself
back on course we'll connect with the
Rey film
um that's coming out of what happens
post of their stuff is oh there's
another galaxy bunch of other stuff yeah
the Ray Charles movie all right well I'm
I'm done talking I'm I've theorized
enough for today now we've all have
especially John he won't stop yeah
kitchen and so many theories based on
the extended novel we've got stuff guys
it's gonna be crazy close this out John
guys what did you think of this episode
leave your nitpicks why do you think
this is the worst thing Star Wars has
done yet or inversely why is this the
best thing Star Wars has ever produced
leave it below and we'll catch it for
episode three next week is it Barris I
want to know what the audience thinks is
it bear new question forget all that is
it marriage Ezra
oh
[Music]
it wouldn't make any sense but
stature wise yeah I see it yeah stature
wisely what if that's Zeb
all right
well guys become ourselves become all
Dawn gone
pick your favorite fan Theory and leave
it below and maybe uh is it a fan Theory
or a conspiracy theory at this point
your fan conspiracy theories pick your
favorite and let lucasfilm know that
that's what you demand from the reveal
in the finale coming up much love and
we'll see you next time force be with
you and all that good stuff I love you I
know peace out
[Music]